في مؤتمر صحفي قال فاروق بوعسكر رئيس
الهيئه العليا المستقله للانتخابات في
تونس ان العدد الاجمالي للناخبين بلغ
مئتين 270,000 ناخد الى حدود الساعه 10:00
صباحا في حين بلغ اجمالي عدد المسجلين
اكثر من تسعه ملايينب اضاف ابو عسكر ان
عدد المرشحين بلغ الف وخمسه وخمسين مرشحا
بينهم واثنتان 122 امراه فقط
[موسيقى]
معنا من المكتبه الاعلاميه لهيئه
الانتخابات في تونس مدير مكتب الجزيره
لطفي حجي لطفي كيف يتطور المشهد في تونس
سواء على صعيد المشاركه في عمليه الاقتراع
وايضا على الصعيد اخر مواقف السياسيه
نعم انسي هي المشاركه وصله وصفها رئيس
الهيئه العليا المستقله للانتخابات فاروق
معسكر بانها معتبره بعد ساعتين من انطلاق
ال ال الانتخابات وحين قرنا بين
الانتخابات السابقه اعتبر انها في نفسي
النسق تسير في نفس ان سقف انتظار الساعات
المقبله التي يتوقع ان يرتفع فيها النسخ
باعتبار ان التونسينا وخاصه فئه شباب منهم
كما يقولوا اعضاء الهي تصوتوا بعد منتصف
النهار وقد تجنب فاروق ابو عسكر حديث عن
النسبه الان تحدث عن ارقام فقط وقال ان
النساء بدل لا يجب ان تخفي عنا
الارقام الارقام الناخبين الى حد الان
واضح ان الهيئه ستجد نفسها في مقارنه
دائما مع الانتخابات البرلمانيه الساب ده
على ثلاثه مرح التي مرت في العشريه
الاخيره وكذا لانه سيتطرح تحدي امامها
نظرا لانه هذه الانتخابات هناك احزاب تدعو
الى مقاطعتها وهناك تخوف من الراي العام
تخوف من الملاحبين ومن الهيئه الناس ان
تكون نسبه المشاركه ضعيفه خاصه وان
الزملاء صحفيين المنتشرين في مواقف في
مكاتب الاقتراع المختلفه المختلفه يلاحظون
سوا في تونس العاصمه او في المحافظات ان
هناك اكبر
الانتخابات السابقه هذا هو الاساسي
بالنسبه للانتخابات
جرائم انها توحيد كل جريمه مباشره الى
النائب العام للنظر فيها في اقرب وقت كذلك
يتحدث قدم همم
عن الدوائر التي همم ستجرى فيها انتخابات
اخرى دوره ثانيه في يناير المقبل لان
القانون الانتخابي يقول اذا ترشح مرشح فقط
فانه يفوز الين هناك 10 دوائر ستكون فوز
ثاني بالنسبه للدواء التي
اثنين يفوزوا النائب الذي تحصل على اكثر
اصوات من منافسي اما الدوائر همم التي
يترشح فيها اكثر من الاثنين فان او اذا لم
يتحصل الفائز الاول على النسبه 50 زائد
واحد من الاصوات فانه تجري همم انتخابات
اخرى
ان تكون هناك دوله اخرى من الانتخابات
في تونس
[موسيقى]